[Musique]
afin de valoriser au mieux le territoire
réunionnais le département a lancé ce
mercredi 8 février avec ses partenaires
le label 100% la réunion un label qui se
veut être une garantie sur la
traçabilité des produits d'origine
animale végétale ou transformés dans les
compositions sont issues en totalité de
la production réunionnaise
nos produits nos produits qu'on retrouve
aujourd'hui agricoles produits
maraîchers viandes et diverses produits
venant de cette terre réunionnaise mais
parfois on ne sait plus aussi si
lorsqu'on achète un produit fabriqué
est-ce que ce produit ne contient que
des ingrédients venant de la terre
réunionnaise et bien nous avons voulu
donner de la transparence de la
lisibilité et ces pour cela que nous
avons lancé 100% la Réunion
et et là pour rassurer le consommateur
c'est de dire que oui c'est une
production de la Réunion et par son acte
d'achat il va aider l'agriculture de la
Réunion cette nouvelle marque est
l'aboutissement de plusieurs mois de
travail et d'études 100% la réunion se
décline en trois versions nous allons
lancer une grande campagne de
communication pour mettre en valeur ces
produits de la Réunion 100% réunion qui
va se décliner en trois le label 100%
Réunion c'est l'origine réunion le label
excellence 100% Réunion c'est tout
simplement un produit qui a pu
bénéficier une reconnaissance nationale
internationale une médaille et puis
enfin le 100% réunion bio vous l'aurez
compris ce sont donc les productions bio
qui sont issues de la production
réunionnaise qui seront donc mis en
avant une quarantaine d'agriculteurs ont
déjà collaboré à la marque pour eux ce
label permet de donner plus de clarté
aux consommateurs
vous aurez la garantie que la Réunion
d'ailleurs que bah c'est vraiment un
Labé qui n'est pas seulement dit pour
nous mais ça n'a pas été trouvé par
l'administrative on va dire voilà les
consommateurs pourront retrouver tous
les produits de labellisés 100% la
réunion sur le site Internet 100%
réunion.fr et bientôt sur les étals des
marchés ainsi que dans les rayons de la
grande distribution
[Musique]